[Music]
before we get into all of the new
information and there's a ton of it
tonight I want to remind you that for
over a year Democrats members of the
biased abusively biased press all
breathlessly talking about Russia Trump
collusion hysteria breaking out almost
every night they were acting like the
worst scandal in American history
meanwhile there were so many prominent
Democrats and former Obama officials in
spite of all of us they were saying
there's smoke but there's no fire for a
year no evidence but there's thousands
of hours of television coverage we knew
by listening to people it was never true
what's US have you seen anything that
suggests any collusion between the
Russians and the Trump campaign well
there's an awful lot of smoke there
let's put it that way people that might
have said they were involved to what
extent they were involved to what extent
the president might have known about
these people or whatever there's nothing
there from that standpoint that we have
seen directly linking our president to
any of them the last time we spoke
senator I asked you if you had actually
seen evidence of collusion between the
Trump campaign and the Russians and you
said to me and I'm quoting you know you
said not at this time has anything
changed since that we spoke last well
not you know it hasn't I know we need to
go soon but just to be clear we haven't
there has been no actual evidence yet no
it has not at the time I left I did not
have seen any smoking gun certitude
evidence of collusion is there any
evidence of collusion that you have seen
yet is there well there is a lot of
smoke
we have no smoking gun at this point see
that and despite the destroyed Trump
media in their desperate attempt with no
evidence they did not stop breathlessly
hysterically reporting these lies the
so-called Trump Russia collusion watch
them we have a president's campaign in
their Criminal Investigation for dealing
with a foreign adversary historian
Douglas Brinkley says there's a smell of
treason in the air you told The
Washington Post last week that quote
there's a smell of treason in the
when it comes to this investigation a
lot of people are afraid to use the T
word treason but in the end that's what
people are investigating the Republican
Party is now actively shielding this
treasonous megalomaniac he knows that he
is smack in the middle of this
investigation having to do with perhaps
treasonous activities
now tonight one of the most important
things sadly we conclude is that the
media and the Democrats in this country
and their attacks or purely purely
political they never wanted the truth
now we even have real evidence that the
FBI uncovered a Russian plot that
involved we have real evidence bribery
extortion blackmail money laundering
racketeering they knew in 2009 that was
one year before Hillary Clinton and the
Obama administration approved this
corrupt uranium one deal and what we've
learned this week is that the FBI the
Department of Justice all knew in 2009
that this was happening inside our
country and they did nothing to stop it
so the same Democrats the same media
outlets that was screaming bloody murder
for a year
lying to you every day for a year about
Donald Trump are giving next to zero
coverage to this story now keep in mind
we have an FBI informant in this case
who infiltrated this Putin Network right
here in America he has evidence he has
emails he has personal recordings he has
documents he has insider knowledge of
all this that America's national
security was in fact compromised at the
highest level our country was sold out
right in front of our faces they let it
happen then of course you have the
explosive new details about the phony
fake salacious news dossier now we now
know that the Clinton campaign the DNC
paid over nine million dollars to help
fund these lies this propaganda hid
piece that the Russian government
sources gave them now make no mistake
this was nothing short of a
collaborative effort with the Russians
to manipulate the outcome of the last
presidential election and we have the
proof also we have to point something
out since everyone is so worried about
Russia collusion isn't it interesting
at no point did any Democrats my
overpaid liberal media friends or Robert
Muller or members of his team
none of them they wanted to get to the
truth none of them asked the one man on
this earth that knows the truth that
wouldn't know the truth and I'm talking
about the WikiLeaks founder that's
Julian Assange
he is the person the one individual that
posted the information about the DNC
emails no one ever took the time to do
what we did and talk to Julian Assange
I've talked to him now on air five times
now because they knew what his answer
would be and they didn't like it he was
telling us again and again it was never
Russia it was never a state that it was
never a state party now all these
scandals and the ensuing cover-ups add
to what I am telling you now is the
biggest betrayal of you the American
people that I can think of in my
lifetime the American people have now
been regularly lied to you have been
misinformed
you have been propagandized by a
political party and abusively biased
liberal media that have literally no
interest in helping the people in this
country or telling you the truth
to them everything obviously is about
politics and about advancing their rigid
radical left-wing ideology now with all
that said here's all the new information
we have tonight on the fake news dossier
Hillary Clinton has been completely
silent so far Clinton has yet to say
anything publicly about financing a
document that use current and former
Russian government sources to create the
most obscene salacious completely
fabricated accusations about Donald
Trump
now since Hillary Clinton is refusing to
talk about her role in the dossier what
we decided to reach out to Clinton
spokesperson for comment big surprise
it referred us to other people including
the law firm that the Clinton campaign
used the fun fusion GPS in a statement
we did get from them it said in part
quote Hillary for America and the DNC
complied with all campaign finance laws
well that's informative now Hillary
silence on this is beyond telling now
sources have told the New York Times
that Hillary Clinton only learned about
the dossier when BuzzFeed publish
it back in January really Hillary has
such a great track record of telling the
truth now the current DNC chairman he's
running as far away as he can and
claiming he knew nothing about it
and disgraced former DNC chairwoman
debbie Wasserman Schultz she's saying
she had no idea what was going on and
according to a report Clinton's campaign
chairman John Podesta told Congress that
he wasn't aware of any of these payments
nobody knows nothing how is it possible
then that over nine million dollars went
out the door and people in charge had no
idea that that money was being spent but
meanwhile so many Democrats were Gurjit
ated the lies just like the media now
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan announced
today that the FBI will cooperate with a
House document request about this
dossier this is a huge development and
we're going to be following that closely
also tonight Fox News has learned that
congressional hearings with the FBI
informant who is the key witness in this
Russian bribery scheme will also be with
the chairman and ranking members of the
committee's only and Fox News is also
told that Senate Judiciary Committee
Chairman Senator Chuck Grassley he
rightly is pushing for public hearings
with the FBI informant now we have to
remember that in each of these scandals
laws were broken Fox News legal analysts
Gregg Jarrett has put together a list
for us take a look at the side of the
screen these are all the laws that were
potentially broken by the Clinton
campaign and the DNC in the fake news
dossier scandal and there's the uranium
1 scandal
oh great Jared back at work you have
federal statutes involving crimes like
bribery mail fraud wire fraud
racketeering beyond serious stuff this
is go to jail type of things
now we also forgot about the Clinton
email server scandal by the way they're
now up on the side of your screen two
House committees finally this week are
looking into how the FBI and the
Department of Justice during the Obama
administration handled these issues and
for good reason James Comey let Hillary
Clinton off the hook despite the
overwhelming amount of evidence of
wrongdoing so with all this new
information the big question tonight is
who
knew what and when with uranium one the
FBI had mountains of evidence of Russian
bribery did President Obama know about
this was it in President Obama's daily
presidential briefings apparently that
might have been told to the lawyer of
the FBI informant and what did Hillary
Clinton know and when did she know did
she know that her husband Bill Clinton
was being paid double his speaking fees
for a speech in Moscow did she know that
bill asked for permission while in
Moscow to meet with Russian nuclear
officials did she know that eventually
bill met with Putin during the trip and
advocated as important he also advocated
that in fact the Iranian one deal be
done and also was paid by a bank that
had a financial interest in uranium one
so how could both of them Obama and
Clinton ever think ever it's a good idea
to give 20% of America's uranium to
Vladimir Putin now by the way that's the
foundational material for nuclear
weapons we need to hear from key Obama
administration officials for example
like Aaron Eric Holder what did he know
and when did he know it he was in charge
of the DOJ they're in charge of the FBI
did he know about the evidence of
Putin's Network right here inside the
United States all the crimes being
committed in 2009 before it this uranium
one deal was approved in 2010 now
remember Eric Holder Hillary Clinton
they were part of the committee that
signed off on this deal personally Eric
Holder did Hillary did and there's
Robert Muller he was the FBI director
back in 2009 how inconceivable is it
that he didn't know that Russian
operatives were in our country trying to
break into the Iranian market on behalf
of Lad Amir now how can he possibly
oversee any investigation into any
Russian collusion next we got rod
Rosenstein he was in charge of the
investigation into this Russian bribery
plot how does he not have a conflict of
interest then we have to ask James Comey
what did he know and why didn't he act
and there's also questions about the
phony dossier how is it possible these
same people didn't think it was
necessary to tell you the American
people tell Congress that the Clinton
can
when the DNC paid for it you know what
we are working hard day and night you
deserve answers to every one of these
questions but one other important thing
that we have to tell you about tonight
before we bring in our guests we now
have proof that intelligence wasn't the
only powerful government entity that was
weaponized by the Obama administration
now you may remember I talked about five
forces against the president one of them
is the deep state they weaponized the
power of intelligence to use against
this president just a few hours ago the
Department of Justice announced they
reached a settlement with multiple Tea
Party groups that were targeted
specifically by the Obama IRS because of
their political ideology
now the settlement includes payouts to
several Tea Party groups and an official
apology from the IRS which now admits
that their actions during the Obama
years was quote wrong
you think so using the IRS targeting
people that you don't like or agree with
now remember much of this IRS
weaponization occurred under the
oversight of Lois Lerner while many of
these Tea Party groups were in the
critical initial stages of forming a
resistance to the policies of Obama that
stopped them dead in their tracks and
many of the Tea Party groups were
prevented from organizing and instead
was spending all their time all their
resources all their money to combat what
was persecution from a politically
inspired IRS okay the apology and
settlement great but a day late and a
dollar short and Obama got a free ride
in 2012 as a result so ultimately the
Democrats got everything they wanted the
Tea Party became distracted ultimately
fractured and President Obama was
re-elected for a second term in 2012 we